and we are right now joined by magnus
carlson uh
and your reaction magnus after that last
uh
last game uh no it was okay i made a
mistake pretty early on and then i
just had a very bad position um
i probably could have fought a little
bit better there by not taking
uh taking on d5 but it was it was
difficult
uh anyway i'm uh
i'm fairly happy with the with the drone
today uh
so i'll just try and uh um
push a little bit harder tomorrow there
was one move
in that last game that i noted i think
it was the 22nd move
and david howell our expert said uh
no way will magnus carlsen uh move his
pawn hair to take the white pawn
no chess player would ever do that and
then you did magnus
why why did you make that move uh
opening up for the king there
uh which one oh
i just thought uh rook f6 uh e4 was
very very bad so i i thought uh
with the gf6 at least keep some
stability
uh no i mean i i just um
i miscalculated something something
before
that was uh that was a problem but with
the the way this game
ended then do you sort of regret going
into that very quick draw in
in your last white game no i was
uh i was knackered so i needed uh
i was needed a short game ah
and okay so the second game was um a
crazy game
what did you think of that opening that
wesley so made there
i was kicking myself a little bit for
for allowing it because i was checking
this stuff
during vacancy but not um not today for
some reason
uh for whatever reason i thought he
would go for the
the quiet line so yeah that was really
uh
kind of stupid um magnus were you aware
that
actually the position for 21 moves it
did follow
uh wesley so's chessable course oh now
if i'd been aware of that i wouldn't
have played it
will you be tempted to watch some of it
tonight maybe
uh maybe i'll make others do it
well minus a final day of the final
tomorrow
you've had super good first days in the
knockout stage
now you're tied uh does that mean we'll
see a very aggressive
magnus crossing on the second day uh
i will uh i'll certainly be more
aggressive
with with white that's for sure and
magnus we've had a lot of fun in the
studio today because we've seen a few
videos
where you uh pick out your fantasy chess
teams what the
chess players you would have on your
fantasy team and wesley so
almost made it and with his play maybe
especially in the second game today
would you make maybe take him back in
uh i don't know yeah
i also have a question so we've been
asking our viewers
which famous athlete would be the best
chess player
so which one of the celebrities that
you've played has been surprisingly good
uh i don't know nobody has
blown me away after that
all right magnus um we're excited about
tomorrow hope you are as well
good luck thank you